so we're going to start with just a
quick little summary of what webassembly
is this talk is not designed to teach
you all about the details of webassembly
instead we're going to talk about how
you can use webassembly on server-side
applications but we do want to summarize
to make sure we bring along as many
people as possible with us along for the
journey so webassembly is a little bit
like some things that people have tried
before strike stop me if this sounds
familiar you can write your apps once
and run them anywhere of course you've
heard that java silverlight flash this
promise has been made many times but
this time it's different with
webassembly we have an open wc3 standard
that's already supported on the devices
you already use and love all of your
major browser vendors it's incredibly
efficient and fast and it's polygot like
it's not like java it doesn't come with
its own programming language it allows
you to take code that you have and then
recompile it down to this intermediate
format it runs everywhere and what's
powerful about web assembly is is that
these little engines
these wasm runtimes can be tuned for
different circumstances so for example
you might want to have your code running
on big silicon in the cloud and you can
have a webassembly runtime like wasm
time that's tuned for that or perhaps
you want to do some
just in time compiling or ahead of time
compiling out on the edge and you want
to use
a runtime that's tuned for low power or
low memory
you can still use the same code and port
them to both so this is a very portable
technology and one of the most powerful
things that we will talk about is that
it's a very safe technology but i'm
going to hold that value prop for a
moment
let's talk about what we mean when we
say cloud native you know when we talk
about cloud native we're really talking
about this third epic in the last 25 or
so odd years of computing where
20 years ago
even longer than that at this point 25
years ago people started to realize when
they were building data centers that
there was an opportunity to be more
efficient and uh virtualization came out
and that really was accelerated with the
public cloud and the key move that
happened there is that the security
boundary moved from the box itself you
know the the dell server the ibm server
up to the cpu and there were a lot of
crazy implications in that
and then a few years later we sort of
entered the epic that we're in now with
containers and people said god you know
i used to build these images and it
would have
you know raid controller firmware in it
and that was crazy and why am i doing
this with
my uh software applications shipping and
tire operating systems so a
virtualization layer
you know containers was put together and
coupled with kubernetes it's really come
to dominate the landscape
but we're going to talk a little bit
about how the technology technology we
have today does not meet the challenges
that we have today and we're going to do
that by looking at the modern computing
environment
this
picture of the world is really what is
going to drive the next 20 years of
change and we say that and i think that
because
containers uh will work on much of this
infrastructure when you think on the far
left side of this image we have the
central public cloud and on the far
right we have the tiniest devices in
your lives tiny watches refrigerators
things like that there is a continuum
where kubernetes will work great it will
continue to go out to the edge and
containers can be brought there but
there are an increasing number of cases
that do not depend on linux
nor will run kubernetes and an easy one
i'd point out is your web browser which
is probably one of the most common ways
that you interact with software today
never mind all of these tiny devices
lower power and memory constrained
devices these are are not these will not
work and there is some lower bound where
we can take today's technology
so what are the problems what are the
additional problems that we have with
today's technology
uh yesterday we hosted the second cloud
native webassembly day and uh my good
friend ralph askwe and i spelled his
name wrong there sorry ralph
actually equipped that in the new there
is no edge in the new cloud and i think
he's absolutely right
i just had this article posted in uh the
new stack last monday
but there are these compelling reasons
when if you want to sit and have the
discussion on where will compute live in
the future you know will it all just
live centrally on the far left side of
that diagram in the public cloud and
everything on the far right is dumb and
just makes api calls and i would argue
absolutely not for at least these five
reasons there are latency and
determinant deterministic reasons why
you need to make decisions locally think
like your tesla you want real time
there are privacy and security reasons
why you would not want to ship personal
data out of a particular environment
there are times when you want liber
limited or deliberate autonomy think
like drones or things that go offline
think of my refrigerator if it's
disconnected from the public cloud it
better still keep things cool
oftentimes on the edge is where the data
is they give your nest doorbell it
doesn't ship all of that
data back to the central cloud it does
pre-processing first to select key
images that have faces and other things
and then ships them back
and regulatory reasons you know gdpr
ccpa regula regulation is an invest move
right now we're going to have far more
regulation in the near future than we've
ever had in our industry in the past and
if we accept that the future of
applications is distributed then we also
accept that there are some significant
problems that we're going to have to
deal with and we're going to talk about
these a little bit but the first one is
a diverse set of system architectures
the second one is is that the
application architectures themselves
will be different how many times are you
using peer-to-peer technologies for
example device to device that don't even
transit the public cloud
system security how do we how do we
reuse this code and deploy it everywhere
and keep it safe
offline use and machine learning there's
a link to the article in the new stack
if you'd like to read a couple page
paper about our article about
the further reasons there but let's walk
through the three key challenges in
today's computing environment that are
driving the rise of web assembly
the first is portability this diverse
execution environments that we need to
be able to run in places where we have
different cpus different operating
systems or even neither of those like
the browser where we just sort of have
an execution environment
the second big reason is security across
that new continuum of technology how are
we going to secure this and lock this
down containers are scoped to a linux
process
how do we take a security model that's
scoped to a linux process to places
where we don't even have linux or
processes for that matter
and the third big reason is the one
we're going to spend the most time on
because i think that this is the
opportunity for the biggest innovation
in technology period especially when
coupled with webassembly and it's the
tight coupling that we currently make
between applications and their libraries
or capabilities that they use we'll
tease that apart in a moment let's go
through these one at a time
so this first challenge is portability
we are on the way to 50 billion internet
connected devices by 2030. that is a
phenomenal number and collectively this
represents as much if not more
computational power than we have in the
cloud itself
if this is the new cloud then we have a
whole new set of challenges here but
what i would emphasize is is that yes
there's a story around arm and power pc
and mips and all of the long tail of
risk chips that you find out in today's
ecosystem but this is also a problem in
data centers think of the amd graviton
64-bit arm processors that they've
launched
when we build containers today we make
an implicit assumption and we target a
specific cpu architecture so another
case where containers don't fail and if
you suddenly have to support dozens or
hundreds of different
architectures having an intermediate
format like webassembly is a huge win
so for this first big challenge i think
it's clear webassembly brings a lot to
the table and it's something that can be
considered let's go to the second big
challenge what about the security of
these things
now this idea of capability driven
security is not new any of the linux
networking uh
you know geeks in the audience have
probably used you know pseudo-setcap
before to give privileges to snort or
shurikata or bro or something to monitor
a network interface but it's the idea
that the children no longer inherit the
permissions of the parents and web
assembly really embraces this capability
driven permissions in that if you want
to access a file or a folder then you
have to be specifically granted to it
webassembly is denied by default and
you're becoming increasingly familiar
with this think five or ten years ago
when you installed an application on
your phone it just installed today it
actually prompts you on a line-by-line
basis for access to the video camera to
the microphone and the other
capabilities
that same model is coming to our cloud
software and then we're going to extend
that so for this second big problem i
think webassembly is another great fit
it brings us a more it brings us a more
portable more granular security model
that runs everywhere that feels like a
win-win it runs at near native speed
so let's carry this forward a little bit
what about this third problem
you know in um in french there's this
wonderful word elan and it's to
translate it directly i think that means
something like momentum but it's so much
more than that it's that moment right
when the bird has got its wings flapped
and it's about to take flight or when
the dancer is spinning it's her leg
faster and faster and faster and picking
up momentum right that's the elan
and what what really um i think is a big
opportunity to ride this webassembly
excitement
is to consider this tight coupling here
because this tight coupling that we have
acts as an anchor that holds us in place
if you're building for a specific cloud
provider and you're using specific cloud
provider services who cares how portable
your code is
if you're stuck in that particular
location so we've seen this rise of
actor models in technologies like
wasmcloud and in technologies like
dapper where instead of binding to
specific libraries you bind to a
contract and on the other side of that
contract just like a lego block you can
plug in different capabilities
so these are the capabilities that you
would use to satisfy all sorts of things
in your app if you're building a
[Music]
an application to calculate loan
interest or you're building some social
media scoring or you know any kind of
business logic that you want to put into
it
you have to typically couple that with a
large amount of non-functional
requirements and the enterprise that's
just extreme and you have to start
coupling it with security and logging
and other sorts of
tools and the dirty secret of enterprise
application development especially on
the server side is is that the vast
majority of the application
code base
is someone else's code
it is nearly criminal that in today
modern cloud native app development you
start each new application with 20 000
lines of someone else's code and there
are some devastating impacts to that the
private studies that i've seen in some
enterprises was even higher as many as
as much as 99
of their template some java spring boot
application was non-functional
requirements that they were managing and
those non-functional requirements act as
a weight that holds you in place there
now across this microservice life cycle
when you accept all of those
non-functional requirements you end up
with some pretty devastating impacts the
first is is that you have an inability
to move things from design quickly out
of poc into production because there's
completely different assumptions that
are made that are non-functional
the second is is that building your app
means that you have a lot of boilerplate
code that you have to manage and run
deploying this having to build pipelines
for each different cpu architecture or
each different device becomes a long
tail of non-functional requirements that
you would just select i need one set of
security primitives for
android another for ios yet another for
my edge devices and yet another for my
core cloud
functioning and the last
is by far the most devastating and if
you've worked at an enterprise you're
constantly hounded by these high medium
low vulnerabilities in that 20 000 lines
of code that you need to patch and
maintain
and all of that holds you back from your
core purpose of building and deploying
business logic
so this tight coupling that we see at
the top layer
really becomes one of the biggest
challenges that we're facing in modern
cloud native development and with
webassembly today and its adoption to
meet the first two challenges there it
comes a huge opportunity as well to
solve for the third
so um i'm one of the co-creators of an
open source cnc framework that's called
wasmcloud
and it's both compatible with but not
dependent upon the current cloud native
stack and we're going to look at a
couple demonstrations of running things
all together while also running for the
edge and as i mentioned before this is
not the only approach there's microsoft
has put out a wonderful application
layer uh a tool that is
directly aligned to cloud native it's a
sort of depends on containers in the
ecosystem so it would meet the first
left half of the cloud native world but
doesn't
solve for the
far right half here
so in both of these models you
essentially start to adopt this contract
driven approach
instead of importing all of this
non-functional code you simply import a
small contract and the goal of wasmcloud
is to sort of flip those numbers on
their head and make your applications 95
business logic and only 5 non-functional
code
because on the other side of these lego
blocks these contracts you can hot swap
at runtime into different
actual requirements there
so
now this isn't even a new idea
it's a little different to start
thinking from the top down to start at
the business logic and work your way
down but to me this is the next obvious
step in
um the continued epics of technology and
when you think about the landscape today
we already have layers that are doing
this for us just in a different domain
for example on top of kubernetes we
could layer istio and istio would just
remove some of the network-related
concerns such as traffic routing and
role-based access control and on top of
that we could even use dapper which will
give us this application layer concerns
like the key value store but wasn't
cloud takes it even further and really
turns your business logic into these
composable actors it's more of a shift
and we couple it with both elixir on the
back end
for extreme scale and for
and with gnats
so you get a networking layer on the
front end
so let's slide into our first demo
now this is an incredible demo that
completely surprised me it came out of
nowhere and i'm only going to give you
the summary of this one because the full
talk is definitely worth your time this
was showed at wasmcloud i'm sorry a wasm
day cloud native wasm day yesterday and
this was a a group called red badger and
they did this on behalf of a large
financial service and to help set the
stage a little bit this organization
had a number of service interruptions
with some of the public cloud outages
over the last year and they have their
regulators asking them when can they go
multi-cloud
so
what they do in the demo the source code
is linked right here if you want to go
ahead and grab a quick link you can spin
this up yourself but i'll set up the
scene a little bit further
in this demo what we're going to have is
we're going to have the same compiled
code deployed to two
different clouds in this case aws and
gcp
and you can see that we have a set of
steps here and this basic microservice
that implements the to do spec
common reference application that people
will implement in a language for a fun
and example
and what we're going to do as we kind of
walk into this is
we're going to start failing over live
from one cloud to another as we delete
parts of the application we'll just go a
little chaos monkey on it
now logically what's happening here is
this view of the world in which case you
have
gcp on the left and you have aws on the
right and the nats the cncf nats project
gives us a sort of application layer
view that seamlessly connects these two
environments so it does the auto
discovery and it does partitioning we'll
talk a little bit about that in a moment
and we'll start by just running things
in the happy path we'll send we'll curl
send a curl request into into gcp uh and
they'll be resolved and then we'll send
curl requests into aws
and they'll be resolved and then we're
going to
start deleting components and we'll
watch the application still function
normally without any changes whatsoever
to the code and it happens because of
that crisp separation between those two
layers there
then we'll restore the happy path and
and things will work here so
kind of watch for a time on this
and
hilarious
i can't see your screen
so let me just
okay
oh there we go perfect
perfect dish
um let me skip ahead here a little bit
um this is the talk that we'll see
tomorrow here
and this is the little bit of setup that
we're doing and then we're going to get
to
on the left here
we've got
logically a set of windows just
terminals set up just like in the
pictures so on the left we've got a
gcp.wasmcloud.demo and on the right
we've got aws
and as we start sending
our simple curl commands in here we'll
see that the application functions
normally
and delivers our code on both happy
paths here and as we move into this demo
we're going to start to see
us delete the pods down here at the
bottom which is what we're doing right
now
and the gcp path is now unhappy it
doesn't have all the components in the
microservice to complete it
but the sort of the technology here is
going to auto fail
right over to
aws and as we watch the request come in
here this really is a very interesting
demo so i kind of wanted to summarize
this one for you and encourage you to
watch this when it hits youtube in two
weeks 13 days from today
we'll tweet this out off of our accounts
but this is a great demo and all the
code is linked right off the previous
link there as well it's on red badgers
site there
and i really encourage you guys to check
that one out
so let's explain a little bit about
what's happening under the under the
covers here
um the cncf gnats essentially gives us
the ability to create these uh super
super nodes and leaf clusters here so um
in when you can satisfy a request
locally these requests are being routed
locally and in that previous demo we
were running on kubernetes by the way i
forgot to mention that detailed my
apologies so we're running on two
different kubernetes distributions in
the previous demo but at the application
layer we now have the ability to do this
auto discovery and resolution outside of
our local leaf nodes if we can't meet
our make our constraints there what it
means to you as a developer is is that
you no longer have to think about clouds
you no longer have to think about
topology in fact your business logic uh
is completely separated from your
topology and your topology can change at
runtime we're going to demonstrate that
in a live demo we do in just a second
here
so in this next demo what we're going to
do is we're going to do something
similar to that except we're going to
deploy
running code to people in the audience
uh so uh taylor are you connected to the
wi-fi
uh so taylor up here um is uh is running
um wasm cloud as well and what we're
gonna do is we're going to demonstrate
that same ability to fail over here
okay
so all right so this is my local
computer here and i'll just explain the
dashboard a little bit and there's all
of course works via api
and
through a command line click called wash
everything in the webassembly world is
some sort of a wah joke you know uh it's
this is the washboard uh there's wash
there's uh all sorts of wad jokes that
are out there and we're essentially
running the java a pet store has anybody
ever written the java pet store before
no one all right this is like a when you
get into java programming this will be
one of the sort of demos that the books
always use it starts simple and basic
and it gets increasingly and
increasingly complex here
and logically what we have here is an
api that's fronting three other
different actors that are here now
these actors have capabilities they have
lego blocks on the bottom and what's
great is that you can plug them into
lego blocks anywhere
so locally they're plugged into an http
web server and into a postgres database
and that's what's happening here with
these link definitions
now i can also see that there's some
other hosts here that are sitting on the
on the network and
taylor what is your id
are you na6la or nbvu
uh you not you
all right uh
all right steve one of our co-workers is
also connected so this is taylor's
laptop here now taylor do you have
control of the cncf network
have you forwarded any ports or
networking or anything like that
okay so t said that there's nothing but
wasm cloud running gnats on his computer
you can see that taylor isn't uh isn't
run anything so let's go ahead and start
uh part of the application here on
taylor's computer and we'll go ahead and
start
vets which is a piece of this app and
i'm just going to go and kick that off
and i'll give you a demo of what this
app actually looks like
if you're not familiar with it so this
is a simple web scaffolding that we've
thrown on top of it
but there are a couple simple routes
here we've got a pets so we've got a
charlie brown who has a dog snoopy
and snoopy is uh completely paranoid
uh and having hallucinations
especially around halloween so we'll put
that on here
and he's gonna see a diana edwards for
his is that and i can uh click close
here and um
you can see that the um uh that the i'm
sorry i closed instead of add visit
how's my bad
i'll just spell hallucinations wrong
first diane edwards add visit there we
go all right so we can see snoopy's go
has been to the vet now what's really
powerful here is is that
this is all part of this somewhat um
amorphous mesh now so you can see
taylor's running a part of the vets app
and if i come back to
my computer right here you can see that
i'm running it all as well and
we can
you know beyond using the ui we could
also
uh you know curl this you guys probably
can't see that very well if you let me
in the back know when the text is big
enough
great thank you so much
great so i can just curl
and i can see that i could hit that api
now what would happen if we um
you know delete this and this is the
you know the um
the live demo right so let's see what
happens
when we delete it so i'm no longer
running that piece of this application
here locally
and let's see
fingers crossed
[Music]
i really want to scream gold but i'm
miked up sorry to me that's really
exciting
[Applause]
think about what we just demonstrated
there simply
we have two completely disconnected
clouds there's no
vpn between our between our devices here
right i could be running on kubernetes
or not i could be on the edge or not i
couldn't even define the edge to be
honest with you right there is no
definition of that of that term anymore
because there is no real definition of
cloud anymore because all of the old
boundaries have simply fallen to the
wayside
oh
and we could be running on different
cpus
or on different operating systems and we
both are running and compiling the same
code in web assembly as a developer i
love this
because what i don't have to worry about
is everything else
it's simply resolved in the tower of
turtles that live below me and trust me
in modern cloud development eurid's got
nothing on these turtles
right all the way down whatever your
organization's opinionated choices are
you need to run istio you need to run
envoy however quickly they change
all of that simply gets pushed to the
layer below us now and up here at the
developing at the developer layer we're
free to just build our applications and
run them now there's a team that will be
below us that will run those platforms
however they now can stay in their own
swim lane and stay out of ours
this is a huge um
opportunity in uh in cloud
native computing and what i would want
to emphasize is is that
there are multiple approaches to this
you know i'm demonstrating in
wasmcloud today because that's the
technology that i work on but dapper is
also moving in this direction as well
now they haven't adopted a webassembly
so that wouldn't make a great talk about
cloud native applications with
webassembly except not with webassembly
but
this is i think a huge piece of what the
excitement is around with webassembly
so with our last couple of minutes here
let's talk about some of the things that
are working together to make this happen
so wasn't cloud is a cncf project we
started it about two years ago
and it is a stack of components that
give you the ability to
develop very simply and down at the
bottom layer it starts with webassembly
which i like to think of as just a
virtual cpu
you know when you're when you compile
your code to webassembly there's no
virtual operating system here now there
are some operating system-like
constructs on the way called wazi and
when those come along you'll sort of
have the ability to
you know open sockets and
do some of those other things but right
now
this is just simply like a box that
you're locked into
and what wasm cloud does is it comes
along and it brings a framework for your
applications an application framework
that gives you
a box of legos and takes care of a lot
of the hard underlying tasks for example
when you want to move data out of your
box out of web assembly into the guest
operating system and back it does all
that translation for you even with
complex data types
so it's designed for extreme scalability
both horizontally and vertically as you
just saw right now i could spun up i
could have scaled my acres locally to
you know 100 actors
or i could scale horizontally
out and out and across and we leverage
this built-in networking layer called
nats
also open source in order to get that
done so this is extremely
scalable and composable and of course
signed it also inherits the capability
driven model that a webassembly starts
with
now on top of that
we essentially maintain a library of hot
swappable capabilities those are those
lego blocks like web servers and
database uh you know driver type things
like sql servers
message queues
but these capabilities are very easy to
add and we have a new developer
experience with wasmcloud 1.50 which we
just launched last week that give you
wizards in order to scaffold these
things out and get them
built out
on top of that you start running your
actors like the pet store
and then you plug in whatever lego
blocks you want these are stateless and
reactive and they're incredibly tiny
uh and on the back end wasm cloud uses
elixir which is the same powerful
technology that's that's been developed
over the last 20 years to implement
things like whatsapp initially and
discord it's incredibly scalable and
powerful
and then we combine this with nats which
is the magic layer that just enabled
that seamless connection between these
two leaf nodes here
when the vets app could satisfy its
request locally here
just like we did in the aws gcp demo it
did so but when it couldn't
it
bid the contract out over to taylor's
computer and then pulled it back and
that is incredibly amazing for cncf
projects it's self-healing it's
self-forming there's no service
discovery and we just adopted a new
technology called jetstream that sort of
gives you a local cache of what's on the
network
that works there
now when we even i just want to mention
that when we think about what this
topology and what this technology
enables it's going to enable some pretty
crazy things
just as i was able to seamlessly offload
part of my microservice and make
topology detail with taylor here
you can do that across clouds as well
there's no reason that you can't have
part of your application running in one
cloud and part of your application
running in another cloud or on the edge
itself
if you'd like more information about our
most recent demo we just launched uh
0.50 last week there's live videos
training
and for more information
about what we're doing
with the stack and our view of the world
you can come visit us at wasmcloud.com
this is the sort of summary view though
of where i think we're going for the
next epic of technology
and when we look at this world view it
really involves this crisp layer here in
separation between
your applications and what sits
underneath them your business logic and
everything else
and it really starts to meet the sort of
needs that we have today around tiny
composable
portable business logic that we can take
with us anywhere in a way that the
current epic of technology just doesn't
so when we think cloud native i just
want to remind you that
you know webassembly is neither you know
web nor assembly but cloud native is
really kind of getting undefinable as
well
uh as those boundaries kind of fall away
on the edge uh thank you so much for
your time today my name is liam randall
uh wasmcloud.com and then for more
information about our company it's
cosmonic.com thank you